I like to be home watching a TV series  or a movie or something but maybe once  in a while I like to like to go crazy  and dance heaven is different I miss it  so much during the entire year that when  I go there I want to go see everything  there are very very cool bars and I  think they are getting ideas and  references from Europe and decorations  and they're using a lot of rooftops very  very beautiful  the classic mojito I think it's very  good or you can also go to a Floridita  in Old Havana and try the diary the  Diary is a typical drink that Ernest  Hemingway used to have  wait I say thank you you say daiquiri  you were asking what is that but that  one is a good one know what I'm saying  in fact it's not the mojito is a classic  you know super fresh and golden sweet I  like sweet